i just hit 1 000 days without drinking
alcohol stopping drinking is probably
the most powerful personal development
strategy which i've ever
found i've built three businesses bought
five houses
traveled to 15 countries and learned a
ton of lessons about myself
and life in general since i went sober
i'm not
trying to convert you into the church of
sobriety i just want to share with you
the biggest lessons that i wasn't
expecting to discover
when i stopped drinking the first thing
i realized was how much more productive
i was which was
ridiculous some of that was because i
had more time right
saturday and sunday mornings actually
existed for me now
it wasn't just the late nights being
missed and no more sleeping in though it
wasn't even that i wasn't rolling around
in bed for half a day hungover
i had more attention and better focus i
was able to
put my mind onto a single task for a
long time
and the thing is i like getting things
done and being productive
that's a source of happiness for me so
by
going sober i was more productive which
made me happier
and it happened pretty much straight
away another thing i noticed was how
shocked people are when you tell them
that you've gone sober for some reason
alcohol is the only drug where if you
don't do it
people assume you have a problem they
can't believe that you would choose
not to drink it has to be that you're
hiding from a dependency
people either tend to try and take the
piss or be overly sympathetic
to something and check in to see if you
need help the sympathy is
even worse than the piss taking but over
time both of them get easier one of the
most surprising changes was that going
sober forced me to become
truly confident i realized how much of
mine
and other people's confidence on a night
out
was really just dependent on alcohol see
lots of people myself included use
alcohol to make them more
outgoing and charismatic and far more
people than realize it
aren't actually extroverts they're just
drunk the difference between being shy
and outgoing is often just a couple of
beers without alcohol
i had to become genuinely confident i
had to go and talk to
that girl over the far side or speak up
in a group
without the assistance of alcohol coming
in to make it easier it meant
i actually cultivated a genuine charisma
and confidence that i still have now
something else which surprised me was
that going sober made dating harder
with some girls but it was a turn on for
others
most dates are in bars or restaurants
right and
you sit down and you get a bottle of
wine or you have a couple of drinks at a
bar
and not drinking can be jarring because
it makes the other person feel awkward
they might need the drink on a date so
that they have confidence and it's not
just a
silent car crash so some girls
didn't like it but others did going
sober was a signal that
i'm the sort of guy who has big goals
and makes sacrifices
in the moment for big achievements in
the future it
separated me out from all of the other
british lads who
just lived for the sesh to be honest i
think it's selected for the type of girl
i'm after anyway if a girl doesn't have
the confidence to do a first date sober
and can't understand why someone would
rather chase their goals
than a hangover she's probably not for
me i also found that habits were so much
easier
to build building new habits are hard
enough as it is and i'd made it even
harder
by being hungover once or twice every
couple of weeks
there is no chance that i'm going to do
morning meditation or reading when i'm
desperately holding on for dear life in
the midst of a hangover
let alone if i'm still asleep by having
more stability in my schedule
i was able to build the consistency that
i needed to embed these habits
in fact i built a meditation habit five
years ago
the first time i ever went sober and i
still use it today that was a one-time
investment that still pays dividends
next up better sleep was something that
i probably expected to get
and no one feels rested after a night
out even if you spend most of the day in
bed but
over time my sleep generally improved
a lot i found myself feeling more rested
waking up less throughout the night i
don't know if this is
because there were fewer toxins in my
body but i was still working until
three or four a.m multiple nights per
week so i had a lot of optimizing to do
with my schedule
but simply removing alcohol seemed to
have a massive impact
one of the things that i wasn't ready
for was i'd make fewer bad decisions and
have fewer regrets
you can achieve a lot of success in life
simply by
avoiding catastrophes and when you go
out drinking
you tend to make some pretty poor
decisions you cheat on partners
you have arguments with friends you get
into fights you lose your keys you break
stuff and there's something
unfair about doing dumb [ __ ] when you're
drunk because it doesn't feel like
you did it i mean you did it but you
didn't mean to do it
at least now if i messed up or made a
bad decision i could own it and learn
from it over time this meant that i
picked up lessons which i genuinely
valued as opposed to just
don't buy a bottle of jaeger at two in
the morning or don't go to that kebab
shop at the bottom of the street next up
having more money was something that i
expected
because i knew i wouldn't be wasting
money on taxis to and from town
and bottles and tables and takeaways and
deliveries the next day
but because i had so much more spare
time and i was being more productive and
i was building better habits i hadn't
just reduced my expenditure
i'd increased my income then increased
my capacity to increase my income
i was more competitive because i could
outwork everyone else
and still had spare time left over i
also found myself being more
selective with the people that i hung
out with i realized that the only thing
i bonded with some people over was that
we both ended up getting drunk
in the same places each week but beyond
that i didn't
really have anything in common with them
some friends started to drift away which
was
fine but i realized that if they were
genuine friends they'd support me in the
path to bettering myself
and if friends only wanted to be around
me when i was destroying myself along
with them then
maybe i needed better friends and i
discovered that
if i can't stand them when i'm sober
then i definitely need better friends
next up the increased mental sharpness
was something i really didn't
expect because i already thought i was
relatively sharp but over time i found
that my memory and my verbal agility and
my creativity
had all improved far more than i thought
they would
this kicked in really hard after about
three months and it felt like a
brain fog had been lifted even though i
thought
i'd been close to my limit i still had
so much more to gain i imagine it's like
putting on a pair of glasses for the
first time and
seeing sharply obviously i don't know
what
caused this right i'm sleeping better
i'm building better habits i have more
time i'm in a better mindset
but going sober caused the outcome
of a better mental state even if it
wasn't because of the sobriety itself
what the sobriety enabled put me in a
better place mentally
one of the changes that i really wanted
was a more stable mood
if you think about it a hangover is
basically acute
self-induced depression for an afternoon
over time i'd kind of just accepted that
as a way of life
i didn't realize how much that constant
reset to my mood
was just bringing me back down and
limiting my happiness
obviously this didn't mean that there
were no challenges for me to overcome
but it did mean that i was far more
resilient when they happened because
i stopped getting in my own way and
making life
more difficult than it needed to be
something i really
wasn't ready for was how much i changed
my personal integrity
and what i expected from myself i
couldn't excuse
bad behavior and write it off as a part
of being young and dumb and
sometimes drunk i found myself
reflecting more on my actions
why i'd done something what my
motivations were for it
and holding them to a higher standard
without a situation
every couple of weeks with a bunch of
decisions that i could easily excuse by
alcohol
i couldn't hide when i fell short of
meeting this level of integrity that i
expected from myself
honestly stopping drinking has changed
my life
everything improved and got
exponentially better as it compounded
more and more and more
i never had a bad relationship with
alcohol but
you don't know how good life could be
until you take it away
stopping drinking has got me to a place
where i'm more balanced and
confident and happy and successful and a
lot more proud of myself
you don't have to try sobriety but if
you do
it might just change your life
you